good morning Morgan today is Monday
March 15 20 30 - Arkane Studios
immersive first-person sim prey is out
and it has a lot of Secrets that you
might not know about like dishonored in
Deus Ex there are multiple ways to
complete your objectives and interact
with the environment
some are obvious while others require a
bit more digging here are a few things I
wish I knew before starting pray these
are only a few early game tips we found
so far so make sure to subscribe for
more on prey in the future all right
where to begin hmm
what about with this coffee mug or how
about this chair or what about this
trash can as unassuming as these objects
may look they can easily kill you one of
the primary enemies you will be
confronting our mimics these inky slimy
face hugging little bastards can
disguise themselves as everyday objects
and jump out at you when you're least
expecting it sure you can bash every
single object in a room to check to see
if a mimic is hiding I call this the
scientific wrench to matter test but
there are more efficient ways to see if
one of these little monsters is hiding
in plain sight a better way is to use
those ears listen for wet clicking
sounding noises like this
once you've pinpointed the imposter take
out that wrench charge up a swing and
send that little sucker to the moon
the wrench can feel a bit imprecise and
unwieldy though so you might want to use
one of the games many firearms first we
have the glue gun fire this at an enemy
and eventually it will freeze in place
from here you can switch to your wrench
and get in a few swings or fire a few
well-placed rounds into it whatever you
do though act fast because enemies will
break free
freezing enemies isn't the only thing
that glue gun is good for though aim at
a surface and you can create steps and
platforms to help you reach new areas
for example shortly after you get the
glue gun use it to get up here and you
can grab the stun gun early on the glue
gun can also be used to stop electric
junctions and gas leaks apart from the
glue gun you will also find pretty
standard guns like a shotgun silenced
pistol a toy dart and wait hold on why
would I ever need a toy gun on a space
station crawling with aliens well it
turns out you can use the dart gun to
interact with computer monitors and
switches having trouble reaching that
computer bust out your hunters rifle aim
at the desired button and boom you now
have access to the area map you can also
use the gun to distract enemies but I
wouldn't recommend trying to defend
yourself with this thing unless you like
looking at loading screens
while you're exploring the station you
will come across Looking Glass videos
Looking Glass allows you to inspect a
video recording from different angles in
most cases we have found secrets within
these videos so make sure to look at
them from every angle and watch them to
the very end so you don't miss a key
code or a secret compartment if you read
some of the emails and dr. Calvino's
office you might notice that he's very
particular about his thermos as it turns
out his thermos is the key to accessing
his secret stash of neuromas if we
didn't watch the whole video in his
office we might have missed this oh and
when you're done smash that screen with
a wrench because people like to hide
secret passages behind them for some
reason
Alex cut us off in the looking glass
servers time to improvise if you're one
of those people that Lutz everything
that isn't nailed down you one have a
problem and should seek help too
probably notice that inventory space is
limited you can expand your inventory
within the engineer neuro Mod skill tree
or you can just throw all your [ __ ] on
the ground and pick it up later when you
have space but I wouldn't recommend
trying this outside of Morgan's office
especially with valuables if you need
some room on the fly and you have a
recycle charger you can toss all your
junk on the floor drop the charger next
to it and fire a dart at the charger all
your junk will magically transform into
its basic elements you can then use
these resources to create weapons ammo
and other useful items from a fabricator
as you make your way through Talos 1 you
will undoubtedly indulge in some of
those sweet sweet alien powers after you
get the psycho scope and psychotronics
you can invest in powers like kinetic
blasts mimic matter and mine Jack be
careful though if you invest heavily
into these skills the turrets will turn
on you and a frightening beast called
the nightmare will aggressively stalk
you
prey is a deep game and there's still
plenty more to be discovered if you
found something else let me know in the
comments below and if you're still on
the fence about picking this one up
check out our review and progress thanks
for watching what's happening don't know
them do this Jesus
sending you the code to a safe and
directed caltrops office